el ph inicial y el punto de equivalencia
están señalados en la gráfica de abajo
dibuja la curva de titulación de manera
precisa en la gráfica marca la posición
del punto medio de equivalencia en la
curva con una equis ok aquí nos están
señalando el ph inicial y también nos
muestran el punto de equivalencia que es
este de aquí y se encuentra a un ph.d ya
lo habíamos visto el punto de
equivalencia lo vimos así en este
problema el ph que se mide en el punto
de equivalencia de la titulación es de
2.54 y si miren aquí tenemos un ph de
2.54 cuando agregamos aproximadamente 29
punto y algo ya se me olvidó el número
creo que estaba en la segunda parte del
problema pero bueno finalmente estamos
cerca de los 30 mililitros que se
agregaron de la solución de ácido
clorhídrico
punto 25 molar ahí es en donde
alcanzamos el punto de equivalencia y
que corresponde a este ph ahora el punto
medio de equivalencia ocurre cuando
agregamos la mitad de esta cantidad de
ácido así que estará en un poco menos de
15 mililitros y en el problema anterior
calculamos que se encuentra a un ph de
4.77 entonces en un ph de 4.77 nos
quedaría más o menos por aquí y nos
piden que lo marquemos con una equis
entonces el punto medio de equivalencia
es cuando agregamos la mitad del volumen
del ácido y conocemos el ph porque lo
calculamos en el problema anterior ok
ahora sólo necesitamos dibujar la curva
de titulación entonces vamos a ver
primero empezamos agregando más y más
ácido clorhídrico y con eso va
disminuyendo el ph
después llegamos al punto medio de
equivalencia y después se empieza a
estabilizar un poco el sistema y eso es
porque empezamos a tener más y más ácido
conjugado entonces conforme el ácido
reacciona con la base conjugada se da un
equilibrio entre la base conjugada y el
ácido conjugado y después más de ese
ácido se convertirá en base conjugada
así que por un momento tendremos una
solución amortiguador pero al final todo
habrá reaccionado completamente y
entonces llegaremos al punto de
equivalencia la solución se volverá más
ácida y la curva se verá así bueno no es
exactamente igual pero lo importante es
que pasemos por los tres puntos y que la
curva tiene esta forma entonces este es
el punto de equivalencia este es el
punto medio de equivalencia y este es el
ph inicial